welcome to our latest webinar I'm
talking today about building a marketing
machine now I know marketing sales and
marketing is one of the toughest things
for a lot of entrepreneurs you feel you
have a great product a great service but
you got to get it out there and it's one
of the things that hold a lot of
entrepreneurs back including myself was
something to help me back for a long
time you know we believed in our product
I thought I had a great team we had some
great customers but I needed more you
know I wasn't able to to build it up yet
and needed to get out there and start
marketing my business and it's scary and
it means you have to break outside your
comfort zone you have to stretch and
that's part of being an entrepreneur and
today I'm going to give you some
specific strategies for how you can
break out of that mold and start
marketing your business so this is a lot
of entrepreneurs we hate picking up the
phone and doing sales calls and this is
me too I hate cold calling I still do
I'm still not very good at it and if
you're like me and you suck a cold
calling and dread the idea of being able
to pick up the phone and have to call
people to try to pitch your service then
you have to find another way to stand
and I did it through marketing I found
it's a lot easier to convince people to
buy from you when they're coming to you
and they're pre-sold a little bit on
what you do you know they're asking
about what you're selling it's a lot
easier to convert them and you have a
lot more fun then when you're just
reaching out to people in cold calling
them I find that when people cold call
me you know I never really give them
much attention it's never really
something that's interesting for me and
now I don't even answer my phone you
can't find my phone number my website I
don't even know my cell phone number I
don't use the phone that off and except
for external calls you know if your
meeting with me I'm calling you that's
how it works and so I'm not a big fan of
doing telemarketing and cold colonies
myself and I had to find a different way
to stand cold calling can work for you
it can be a great tool but again it's
got to be something that you're good at
if you suck at it you have no interest
in it and you're forcing yourself to do
it you're probably not going to have a
lot of success you have to find a
different way to stand and for me that
was through marketing so I'm going to
share with you today some of the ways
that i do it and hopefully you can apply
some of
lessons to your own business as well so
this webinar is about the final four
strategies they are one get clients
coming to you to create a board of
advisors three tell your story and four
increase your prices and we're going to
touch on all of these in a little more
detail as you go through the
presentation but first a little bit
about me who is Evan Carmichael why
should I pay attention why do I care
about this guy a bit of a background on
me so I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help my passion is
helping entrepreneurs I wake up every
day excited to help entrepreneurs
because I know it's hard running the
business and I know it's hard doing
everything yourself and I want to be
someone who can help you out when I was
19 I had my first company and this was a
biotech software company and again we
had a great product but we couldn't
figure things out at the start and this
is where I cut my teeth and I thought I
tried every single sales and marketing
technique until we finally found a few
that worked and I almost gave up with
this business I was making 300 bucks a
month not able to survive off of that
had to tell my friends know when they
wanted to go out for drinks and dinner
because I couldn't afford the 20 bucks
it would take to go out and see them and
I almost gave up and I almost went back
and got a job and you know sold out and
gave up on my entrepreneurial dreams
until I discovered a few simple
marketing techniques that worked and
suddenly or business started to take off
so i'm going to share some of those
today from there hooked up with a
venture capital company and started
helping raise half a million to 15
million dollars for companies who are
trying to expand and here's the thing
these guys had figured out the marketing
side you don't need to have a lot of
money a lot of success to be able to
raise venture capital but you have to
have something you can't just go on with
an idea and the guys who we were seeing
had figured out the marketing side they
had built their business out they
weren't making it big by any stretch but
they had a model that worked and I
learned from them as well as we help
them raise expansion capital so the good
news for you guys is if you have our
great product or service once you figure
out your marketing machine you're going
to rapidly get past not just upon a
survival but off the massive success
because you have a model that is working
for you and you just need to ramp it up
but you have to do the right things let
me do a quick recap first of the first
ten strategies
those of you who missed the earlier
presentations number one is over deliver
like crazy and the idea here is if you
want to make a sale you want to make it
super easy for clients to say yes the
more expensive it is the more time
consuming it is the harder it's going to
be for them to say yes because they're
afraid so you have to reduce their fear
and the easiest way to do it is to start
on a tiny tiny little project with them
and then you over deliver like crazy you
provide so much value that they can't
wait to come in and do another job with
you and they're going to keep hiring you
back and back and back and giving you
bigger jobs because they know you like
you trust you see that you're doing an
amazing job and you become an important
part of their business or their life but
the key is just to get started on
something I did this with some of my
clients some big brand-name clients I
started off on one tiny little project a
couple hundred bucks and we built it
into something that became a six-figure
business on its own and it just started
with that first tiny little bit of
business and I didn't have to do any
selling afterwards because they kept
coming to me with better and better
projects because each time they asked me
to do something I gave them way more
than the ass for you have to
over-deliver like crazy second is land
bigger deals the idea here is you can
spend tons of time working with little
clients or tons of time working with big
clients and often the same amount of
time working on a small deal as on a big
deal the only difference is how much you
get paid when I was in a venture capital
business we hated doing the smaller
deals and for us a small deal was half a
million dollars because this just says
much work doing that deal a half a
million dollar deal as it is doing a 15
million dollar deal it's the same amount
of work that's just more money involved
and often the bigger deals are easier
because you deal with more sophisticated
people when you're working with the
small guys they care so much about every
dollar that's being spent that they're
going to really hold you to it and
they're going to be super hard often
your best clients are not the ones who
are paying you a lot of money did the
ones who cheapened out and aren't paying
you much and they suck up all your time
so as you build your business you have
to start going after bigger and bigger
deals when you're first starting up it's
okay you know
trying to make money get started but as
you start to grow your business you have
to go up to the bigger deals number
three build a lead generating website so
India here is you want to make your
website a tool to help drive new sales
leads for you and the best way to do it
is start offering value and creating a
relationship as soon as possible my
favorite way to do it is with the
newsletter so you get people to sign up
for your newsletter you get them to
leave their name and information and
then you start building a relationship
with them so that's point number four
get business using newsletters when
somebody first comes to your website you
don't want to just try to sell them
something because you're probably not
going to buy they're going to browse
they're going to want more information
and you can use your newsletter as a way
to start building a relationship and
then start to increase your
opportunities to sell to them once they
know you like you trust you they're more
likely to buy whatever you have instead
of just selling to them right up front
the web is one of the low cost the most
low cost easiest way to drive business
right now and for any entrepreneur who's
trying to boost drop their company you
have to pay attention to it number five
is get results from social media I know
a lot of people have a hard time getting
results from social media people are on
there talking about their cats and what
they eat for dinner last night and I
thought it was stupid I thought Twitter
was stupid going to first signed up but
you have to think are your clients are
your ideal clients hanging out on these
social media networks and if they are
then you need to be involved whatever
your clients are you need to be there
when i first started on twitter i just
did a search for my company name and i
found out the people we're talking about
me they were mentioning my website and I
wasn't a part of the conversation now
luckily everything was good nobody was
slamming me they're all saying good
things but at the very least is an
opportunity to recognize champions
encourage them when people got a message
for me saying hey thank you for talking
about my website that makes them feel
good and the more likely to do it again
I'll so you want the same thing for your
business moving on to the next slide get
in the media getting the media is an
awesome way to go land new business
because people like buying from experts
and to get in the media you can do two
things one you can take out an ad or you
can be an expert and be interviewed the
ad cost a lot of money and people ignore
ads we're being in expert doesn't cost
you any
thing and gets you a lot of recognition
when I was first starting my business I
wanted to be in the media I wanted to
get some recognition and I made a press
release list I made a list of all the
people who I wanted to connect with in
the media who I could say hey I'm an
expert in and every week I create a new
press release which was a story not just
say hey here's how great I am but give
them a store give them an angle that
they can use in their publication and
every time I sent that out I got picked
up by somebody and when you get in media
once it's so much easier to get it again
the next time and again the next time
you're making the lives of the reporters
easier by giving them an expert contact
to connect with the next one form
through Dziedzic partnerships the idea
here is pretty simple you find people
who are already connected to your target
market who already have your customers
and you connect with them and you find a
way to help get them to promote you it's
one of the fastest ways to grow a
business because they already have your
target market all you have to do is find
a way to work together and so when I'm
talking to new entrepreneurs we're
trying to get started one of my favorite
strategies exactly this find people who
are already selling to your target
market and figure out a way to connect
with them have them promote you if it's
some kind of revenue split or they're
just doing it because it's a value ID
service and they want to help out their
customers the easiest way to think about
it is who do people go to before they
buy from you whatever they're buying for
you whatever product or service there's
a chain who are they buying from you
before they get to you in that chain
that's your potential partner because
when they're done with that person they
need to go to you and so that person has
the opportunity to refer clients on to
you the next one sell more to current
customers they do here is simple the
easiest people to sell to other ones
who've already bought from you provided
again you're given an outstanding
service right you're not just trying to
rip people off people who have already
bought from you they like you they trust
you they know you they've had a great
experience and if you can offer more
service to them they're probably going
to buy it so you could think about
offering a new service offering a new
product or just increase in the
frequency in which people are buying
from you
as a great way to be able to generate
new revenue for your business next one
last leave in our back end this ties in
to over-deliver like crazy you have some
really low cost even potentially
money-losing project that you start with
to get your foot in the door and then
you have a way to capitalize on that
down the road it's used a lot of
internet marketing where there's some
really cheap product that somebody buys
it may have a lot of value but the cost
is really low they want to get you on
their list and they'll give up 75
percent commissions on it because they
know if you buy one thing from them then
you'll buy another and another and
another and another the hardest part is
customer acquisition so even if you have
to acquire them at a loss as long as
they stay loyal to you because of the
great product or service you're offering
and I'm assuming you have a great
product or service if you don't you
gotta find one right this is not the
business for you you don't want to be
off promoting crap you got to believe in
what you're selling this advice is only
good for people who have a great part
and they stand behind it so you just
need to find a way in if you do that
people will keep coming back to you and
the last one is test test test you know
with all marketing you got a test to see
what works some things will work well
some things won't you got to keep
testing to find out what is working for
you and keep modifying and don't lose
hope you know the easiest thing the
tasks and I share some examples before
we're headlines so if you're doing a
newsletter test your headlines that's
the biggest thing that's going to come
out the subject line that goes to
people's email box you need to test and
test and test because it can make a huge
difference to whether somebody opens
your email or not and if you're not
opening your email doesn't matter how
great a script you wrote how much value
are offering if people are not opening
it you're not going to get a conversion
you're not going to get a sale and all
all starts with having a good subject
line so every piece of marketing that
you're doing you want to test it test it
test it test it and see make sure you're
getting some results from it ok moving
on the final four strategy so that was a
very quick recap as to the first 10 the
final four again we're going to get
clients coming to us we're going to
create a board of advisors we're going
to tell our story and we're going to try
to increase our prices now number one
get clients coming to you I love it when
clients come to me it's so much easier
to close somebody when they've come to
you
they've researched you out either
through a referral or through your
website they found you they know what
you are all about is so much easier to
convert them into a paying customer than
anybody else than any other source so I
always try to cultivate relationships
and get people to find me instead of me
having to go out I'm not I'm not great
at going out and getting business I
would suck as a telemarketer if I go to
a networking event I'm not the guy who's
hanging on my business card and talking
everybody if I'm on an airplane I'm not
the guy who's talking to the guy next to
me and saying hey I'm Evan Carmichael go
check out my website I only go to those
events if I'm speaking and then people
come to me after the presentation
because he given great guy or they want
to talk to you so that's another it's a
bonus way to get people to come to you
but it's much easier to sell them when
they're coming to you one of the things
that I do is I help brands promote the
entrepreneurs and I help them with their
social media so one of the things that
I'll do is every month create a list of
the most engaged brands for
entrepreneurs and I measure that by
looking at how many people are talking
about them versus how many fans they
actually have that can tell you how
engaged somebody is in your website and
on your Facebook page and most brands do
a terrible job and they want to do
better and the idea here is just make a
list where you rank your ideal customers
you rank them in some metric that you
can help them with so Facebook
engagement is a metric that I can help
my customers with think about your own
business what can you help your
customers do better and how can you
quantify it and measure it then you make
a list and you publish it and you
compare your competition against each
other what it does is it creates a
metric that they may not have been aware
of before and whenever the competition
see how they're ranked against each
other they always want to beat each
other out you know when telcos are going
up against each other or software
companies are going up against each
other they always want to be the best
whatever metric it is they want to be
number one and so you rank them on a
metric that you can help them with so
this is what I use for mine and I'm
always at the top because we have really
good engagement and I know it can help
other brands do it the same improve
their engagement and get better and so
I'll make this list
and help spread the word about it and
companies will come and find me and it's
usually not the top guys the guys are at
the top are okay it's the guys
underneath you know they want to be
number one they want to leapfrog their
competition and they need help to get
there and you can help them so make a
list of your ideal customers and rank
them according to some kind of metric
that pits them against each other and
then publish the list it's going to get
you a lot of credibility in the industry
and will drive some leads in traffic
back to your website one way to find the
leads how do you find who these people
are a service i use is called jigsaw and
jigsaw is an online database it costs
you depend on a program about a dollar a
lead so you can put in whatever position
you want so in this example here I use
marketing manager this is the type of
person I would target in any kind of
organization the marketing manager
there's eighty two and a half thousand
marketing managers in their database
that are constantly being updated and
you only pay if you want to get their
email address and their phone number so
you can see what their name is you can
see what their company is where they're
located when the record was last updated
and if you want to get that person's
contact information you have to pay a
dollar if it ends up not working out the
numbers wrong with the email that just
bounces you get your money back so it's
a great way to build the targeted list
if you need to reach out to people and
say hey I've just made a list of you
versus your competition that you might
want to check out so go check out jigsaw
calm I have no personal affiliation with
them apart from love in their service so
something something worth checking out
if you're building a list the other
strategy to check out is guest blogging
and guest blogging on linkedin groups if
you have your own really popular blog
that's great you know that will help
drive a lot of traffic but if you're
just getting started you don't have a
popular website or popular blog then
find other bloggers who do have a
popular blog that speaks to your target
audience and offer to do a guest post
from them the idea here is they already
have your audience as readers you want
to hit them over the head with some
amazing value some great content that
you really help your clients with so
they look at you and say wow I really
got to get in touch with that guy he
knows what he's talking about he can
help me with mine
campaign blogs are great place to do it
linkedin groups another great place to
do it linkedin group you have to be
approved to be able to do it blogs you
just have to write to the blogger and
when you're writing to a blogger and
asking them to guest post customize it
don't just send some stock letter off to
everybody and say dear site owner I'd
like the blog for you please let me know
if that's possible right customized a
tell them you're a fan show them some
posts that they've done that you really
enjoy and that speaks to you and why see
if they've ever allowed guest post
before on their blog if not it's going
to be hard for you to get in but it's a
great great way to be able to build up
your brand and have an audience of
people who are already your target
market learn about your products and
services a quick way to find that this
is a screen capture of Google there's a
blog search most people don't know about
this google is not just about you know
websites and images you can find
specific blogs to talk about certain
topics so if you are in the business of
brand marketing you could go in search
brand marketing and see which blogs are
talking about it chances are if they've
written about it before and gotten some
traction then another post about it from
a different angle yours would work well
you just have to reach out to the blog
owner and if you're really targeted
towards what they do and you're not to
promotional they're probably going to
say yes you know blogs are struggling
for content themselves a lot of these
guys are solo entrepreneurs they're just
writers they're trying to make a go
there trying to track traffic and if you
give them quality articles they're going
to say yes but you know be human
customize your email let them know what
you want here's an example I get this
stuff all the time this is where most of
my leads come from now I don't do a lot
of outbound marketing a lot of stuff
comes to me because of the content i
create and distribute i don't need to
read this whole email but this came in
yesterday so i wanted to share it with
you guys who that was relevant this is
from melissa who's working with dell she
is an account manager at a at a PR
agency and they're trying to spread the
word about their new XPS 12 so some new
tablets not that computer that you can
flip around I think detach to monitor
super portable the most important thing
here is at
we're on the lookout too and we've
noticed you this is what they wrote to
me and they basically want to send me
their computer for me to check out so
you want to give me a computer fine you
know I might use it we'll see what
happens with it but this happens to me
on a regular basis brains writing to me
to either give me their products demo
their products or hire me for projects
and then you become in a perfect
situation and you can decide who you
want to work with and who you don't
there's a lot of companies I say no to
because they just want me to promote
their stuff you know I only promote the
stuff that I actually use and most of
the time there's no connection to you
know I talked about jigsaw I use those
guys so I'm telling you guys about it
because I think you could benefit from
it even though there's no personal
connection if Dell sends me this
computer and I start to use and i love
it i'll talk about it you know they're
trying to see their stuff but this stuff
only comes to the people who are seen as
experts incredible in your industry and
that happens by you building up a great
website that has lots of content but
also by guest blogging it's a great way
to start up and build some credibility
is to find those blogs and find those
linkedin groups we were target on tues
hanging out and create content for them
and leads will just start to happen it
really is interesting but this is how it
happens and I do 0 again almost any
outbound stuff besides that list that i
do once a month there's no other
outbound activities that i do everything
is coming to me now now it's easy to say
okay Evan you know you're all set up
your establish you've been doing this
for a while of course things and it come
to you but I had to start somewhere
right you got to start somewhere your
goal should be to become the expert in
your industry you got to be the top guy
in your industry right if your passion
about what you do and I hope you are
because otherwise you're in the wrong
business but if your passion about you
do you should be number one you should
be the expert when somebody has a
question about your field you should be
the one that people talk to but you got
to let people know you exist you got to
reach out to the reporters reach out to
the blogger's reach out to the LinkedIn
groups and let them know you exist and
provide amazing value so they're going
to continue to come back to you and
reference you and then your clients will
find you and there's so much easier to
close these guys on deals because they
came to you okay next
create a board of advisors this one is
important because most entrepreneurs
don't have the whole package you know
you can't know everything if you think
you know everything you're wrong nobody
does it alone you need help and that can
come in the form of employees who have
great skills but you also need advisors
you need people to guide you along your
way and now I have two kinds of advisors
I have people in real life who guided me
gave me advice especially with my first
business where I really knew nothing and
they gave me a path that helped but I
also use advisors who have never met
people who are look up to and respect
guys like Steve Jobs and Richard Branson
and Bill Gates and Oprah Winfrey and how
they got started there's a lot of
lessons you can learn from their success
especially people who are in your
industry if you research them and find
out what they did they get started you
can look back and say you know what
would Donald Trump do in the situation
what would Steve Jobs do in the
situation they can give you some
inspiration ideas to help you get to the
next step but this idea specifically is
about creating that advisory board of
real people people who can bounce ideas
off of this man his name is John travel
Eenie and he helped save my business
that software business where i was
making three hundred dollars a month not
able to survive this guy helped pull me
out and he did it by giving me advice
and connection and wisdom that i would
never have had he had built up software
companies before and sold them for many
millions of dollars and he came on to
help us at the start just because he
wanted to help us and it's funny how
mentors will appear when you you know
when you really need them and you're in
the right frame of mind to accept their
wisdom I helped a lot of entrepreneurs
out and there's nothing worse than
getting an entrepreneur come to you
asking for advice and then they don't
take it you know it's so frustrating as
a mentor to see that the person you
trying to help is closed in their ears
and isn't taking action but the people
who do come to me and ask for help and
they take action I want to help them
again I want to see them succeed so you
got to go with open ears willing to take
their advice and
John Kane newest at the right time when
we were struggling and he helped us see
a new path and he introduces the people
who took us to the next step and even
just how we position the company and
talked about it and promoted it marketed
it he helped change how we think about
our business and he gave us new hope he
believed in us you know when things were
down he still told us hey this is this
is nothing you guys got this you can
still make this huge so you need to have
those people who believe in you now how
you go out and find them do a skills
assessment see what you're good at let's
see where you need help so for example
do you need set up experienced sales and
marketing you need help raising capital
do you need legal accounting help
whatever it is you know you're good at
some things you're great at some things
you should be the best in the world at
some things but you also suck at other
things and you got to recognize that you
got to fill those gaps and advisors our
great way to do it and often just the
desire to help is enough for these
people there's a lot of different
structures you got to think you want to
have a formal meeting you know you want
to have a meeting every month we get
together or you just want to have phone
calls or coffee meetings one-on-one with
people as you need their help because
sometimes you're going to need people
for intense periods of time and then not
need to hear for them for a couple
months six months how often you're going
to meet right so the pen some some are
very formal structured and some are more
loosey-goosey it's okay what are you
going to discuss how are you going to
pay them a lot of times you don't have
money as a start-up and for some people
just the opportunity to give back is
enough if they see that you're taking
their advice that's benefit to a mentor
I want to see you succeed I want to see
you ask questions today call in to my
radio show email me with your thoughts
what's troubling you and I want to see
you take the advice I give you and put
it to work like that makes me happy that
fires me up and I don't get any
compensation for it last time I checked
unless I missing something from you guys
but it's rewarding it's the best part of
my day is waking up having breakfast and
looking at the comments that I get on my
youtube
videos when you guys come in and say how
it's changed your life that's awesome
that makes me happy and so sometimes you
may not need any kind of compensation
just buy them coffee buy them dinner you
could make it more formal you could
offer them an amount of money every time
they come out or you could give them
some ownership in your business there's
a lot of ways to structure a deal you
don't have to worry about exactly how to
do it right now the important part is
getting people on board who can help
support you and the way to get started
is to think about the weaknesses that
you have and start asking people hey do
you know somebody who is really good at
XYZ and you may already know people in
your network who would be a good fit and
it's probably not going to be your
closest friends and family there's going
to be someone on the fringe of your
network someone who you've met once or
twice or heard them speak approach them
let them know if they see that you're
hungry and passionate and you really
want to succeed and you're going to
listen to their advice they're going to
at least give you a coughing we need to
talk about it and you take it from there
you know you don't want to go up to
somebody I hate it when people come to
me and say will you be my mentor like
dude I don't know you why would it be
your mentor like that's that's a
relationship that we're starting it's
like asking a girl to marry you the
first time you see them don't don't put
so much importance on it just go have a
meeting make it informal see what you
learn from them see if they like working
with you see if you like working with
them and take it from there but start
reaching out because you cannot do
everything yourself and you need to be
able to build this beyond yourself and
it's not just bringing on a team of
people under you you need people who are
on the same level as you who can give
you advice another way that I do it is
through mastermind groups and these are
groups that I set up here in Toronto of
entrepreneurs who are all beyond the
startup stage usually revenues between
300,000 two million dollars people
trying to get to the next step now they
build up their company to a certain size
a lot of times people have kind of
flatlined and looking how do I get to
that next step and the problem is they
got to their level of success right now
because they're good at something right
they have a good product or service but
they're now being held back by their own
limitations
they're really good at some things and
they suck at other things and so we get
together once a month to help each other
out and we don't put together you know
seven people or eight people who are all
sales and marketers we try to mix it up
you want people from different
backgrounds different experiences
different skill sets because they can
all contribute to each other successes
that's the key to making it work so we
meet once a month and then we have
accountability calls once a week and you
get two things from it first you get
ideas you get some ideas and experience
and connections from people that you
might not have gone before your mind
opens up in a way that wasn't available
to you before when you're just by
yourself because you're surrounded by
like-minded people who have different
experiences and knowledge than you the
second thing is though just hanging
around other entrepreneurs makes you
feel good at least it makes me feel good
you feel like you're not alone and by
hanging out with other entrepreneurs you
get a vibe you get an energy that gets
you excited whenever I'm hanging out
with another entrepreneur I always leave
excited I get new ideas for my business
I'm reenergized again cuz sometimes when
you're by yourself or if you just have a
small team under you it can be hard you
know you get down on yourself you think
about quitting you think about giving up
you think that this is this is too hard
and when you see other people going
through it and you hear what they're up
to you get new ideas new energy for your
business it's so much easier to put that
in and continue to grow and go one more
day at least for me I always get a huge
boost in my energy every time we're
talking to entrepreneurs but especially
after the mass of my meetings so you can
look in your own local area see if there
is any mastermind group that is already
established if not set up your own and
be really picky don't just pick anybody
you're not in there the filled chairs
find people who really fit with what
you're doing you know they may not be
the the same business which is great you
don't want people in your same industry
but they have the same beliefs as you
they are the same ambition and passion
as you for what they're doing and they
fill holes in what you're not good at
doesn't have to be too formal just start
it over coffee start with one person and
build it up from there don't make it so
big that you're too afraid to take a
step next tell your story this is so
important and this is something that I
missed early on with my business people
like to buy from people they don't like
to buy for companies I think we've all
heard that but it's so true you know
when when you tell your story and when
you're passionate about it it catches
Sam Walton used to say that that passion
is like a fever when you're really
passionate about your business other
people will catch it too like a fever
and they'll want to work with you and
that's employees that's customers that
suppliers that's media that's investors
that's everybody if you talk about your
business like it's really boring and it
really sucks and you hate your life
nobody's going to want to work with you
right you got to be excited about what
you do and if even if that's all you
have you're going to get other people
excited they will want to come work with
you and you started by telling your
story you started your business for a
reason at least I hope you did the
people who just start a business trying
to make money never do you got to start
your business with a reason you got to
be passionate about what you're doing
tell your story you don't have to be you
know a YouTube star you don't have to be
really comfortable in front of the
camera just tell your story take a
picture of yourself put it on your
website put in all your marketing
material and tell people why you started
when people read your story and see how
passionate you are about it it
immediately makes you stand up people
will want to do business with you
because they see you they like you they
want to trust you you're going to win
more business so start telling your
story when i had my website i hid behind
the famous entrepreneurs so we have the
largest collection of famous
entrepreneur stories anywhere online and
I used to hide behind those same as
entrepreneurs you know learn from Oprah
learned from Trump learn from Bill Gates
what do you want to learn from me what
do I know and people started to write to
me to say hey hey we want to learn more
about you who's the guy behind this
website who started this whole thing and
slowly slowly I started adding more
information and it took me a long time
took me a long time they get comfortable
with that because in general I'm a
pretty private guy I don't go
around telling everybody every detail
about my life but the more told my story
and it was genuine it's not some fake
story I made up just to tell people the
more I told it the more people liked my
website and wanted to do more with my
website wanted to explore it more and
wanted to find a way to work together
because I'm passionate what I do and you
got to let that shine through so slowly
but surely I started including myself
more and more into the business you guys
can shortcut that make that work for you
now start telling your story put on your
website put your pictures in there at
least put your picture in there and a
short bio of the why you got this
business started this is a buddy of mine
his name was rich he's got a company
called you gotta love he's a
photographer and he is a celebrity
photographer he's work with lady gaga
he's worked with all sorts of big
celebrities and he came to me one day
and I'm like rich good to see you how
are things going you know you must be on
top of the world working with all these
big name people it's like Evan I'm kind
of bored you know I don't like my
business anymore it's such a struggle to
get things to the next step I'm fine
keeping it where it is but you know I'm
not growing and I'm kind of bored like
rich what that's crazy how do you hate
your business you got an awesome
business what would you do if you
weren't doing this business and he said
that he would start to write would start
to write about the things that he was
passionate about I think she's learned
about himself now rich is a little bit
he's a bit off the wall he's an
interesting guy he's a bit of a crazy
guy but in a good way so in ritual would
you write about so he talked about how
he unschooled his kids not not home
schools on schools and how he uses lemon
as a deodorant because he doesn't want
to use chemicals on his body as it rich
this is great you got to write that blog
and you got to make it part of your
business it's like really people people
will think I'm crazy people going to
leave why would somebody want to hire
this crazy guy until rich you're crazy
you are crazy and you should be proud of
that you should incorporate that into
your business because you're going to
get two tons of people come to your
website
the first is going to be the stuck-up
crusty old CEO who sees your website he
sees that blog content about lemon juice
as deodorant and you'll say this guy's
this guy's crazy I'm not going to hire
him and that's fine because you don't
want that guy anyway you're not going to
get along with them he's going to come
once you're not going to have a great
experience he's going to be hard on you
you're not going to have you're not
going to get along because you're not
the same vibe he's going to say this guy
is crazy I don't want to work with him
then you're going to get the Lady Gaga's
of the world who are crazy who will see
your website and say this guy is crazy I
got it work with him and you're going to
have much more fun with them because you
have the same vibe they are your ideal
clients and so you got to share yourself
put yourself into your business don't
think that your business is just your
business life and your personal life you
keep totally separate try to incorporate
them on my website I talked about how I
love salsa dancing I'll dance 20 or 30
hours a week I love the Toronto Blue
Jays I love using my ripstik and going
snowboarding going camping I'll share
all that stuff it creates a bond with
people people will see that and even if
they never met me they feel like they
know me and that makes it so much easier
for them to do business with me because
they feel like I'm a normal guy I have
interest that might be similar to theirs
and I'm trustworthy you want the same
thing for your business if you put
yourself into your business like rich
you'll have more fun doing it you don't
have to keep them separate your personal
in your business life and you'll attract
better clients so start telling your
storm make it part of your business here
a few ideas to get started think about
how did you get started what was the
reason how did you get your big break
what specifically led to you getting
that break where are you now where are
you going what are some goals you have
for your business what are some personal
interest you have and if you're really
gutsy make a video and it doesn't have
to be high quality doesn't have to be
well produced just getting fun on your
laptop turn on the camera and make a
video be passionate about it and it may
take 20 takes or more if you just have
to get comfortable but tell
your story be passion about why you
started the business you don't have to
be a media star to make that happen and
it will help you so much in landing new
business when people see that video and
they can relate to your story they're
going to want to do business with you I
promise last point of the day increase
your prices too many entrepreneurs do
not charge what they're worth they
constantly under value their work and
they don't get paid what they deserve
you need to look at increasing your
prices when you increase your prices you
start working with better clients people
who respect your work people who value
what you do you're going to have more
fun you're going to work with better
clients you're going to feel a better
sense of worth in what you're doing and
you move to grow your business you can't
keep servicing the guys who don't value
your company something that we did at my
software company this is the one that I
was struggling with making three hundred
dollars a month one of the things that
helped us grow was we had tiered pricing
we had two types of clients academic and
corporate universities use our software
and also big pharmaceutical companies
with huge budgets use our software and
instead of selling everybody the cheap
price we kept the cheap for academics
because they had low budgets you know
they couldn't really afford much but we
sold the same software to the corporates
and charged five times as much and so
it's another way into it you know the
guys with the big budget you can charge
more tune if you feel bad about the
little guys then you can still service
them if you need to if you want you if
you excited about it and still charge me
a little bit less but you can't build a
business just off those little guys who
can barely afford you you've got to
start looking at increasing your prices
this is a buddy of mine named Jason he
runs a business called rise online comic
Neil check it out and he does life
coaching for people and he helps them
bust through the barriers that are
holding the back in their lives and he's
really good at what he does if you look
at his website and you look at the
videos that he's done and you see the
reactions of people it's amazing this
guy has changed people's lives it's
crazy to see how many positive
testimonials he has
not just jason is a great guy Jason did
a really good job it's like Jason
changed my life Jason saved me you have
to listen to jason it's crazy the number
of glowing reviews that this guy has and
I met with him not to long ago at a
coffee shop and we were talking about
his business and the challenge he was
facing was he wasn't targeting the right
people and he wasn't charging enough and
it's great to want to help people who
can't necessarily afford your service
and that's that's the kind of guy Jason
is you know he wants to see people
unblock their lives and he doesn't care
you know if you can afford him or not he
still wants to help you and he spent
maybe too much of his time helping the
people who couldn't afford him and as a
result he can't afford to grow his
business and so we talked about
targeting people who now could afford
him and increasing your prices because
you need to charge what you're worth man
you're changing lives that's worth a lot
of money you got to make that money you
gotta go get it and it's not that the
people he was helping didn't appreciate
what he was doing they just weren't his
target market they couldn't afford him
so he calls himself the Ferrari of life
coaching so you got to go after Ferrari
clients you know not everybody can
afford a Ferrari everybody wants a
Ferrari but not everybody can go out and
afford it so you gotta said increasing
your prices have another friend of mine
who likes to do a lot of charity work
and it's great to give back now don't
get me wrong we do a lot at our business
as well but you have to understand too
that you can have a greater impact if
you have a bigger business right you
have to still feed yourself first if
you're unable to get by then you won't
be able to stay around to help other
people so it's great to have a portion
of your business that gives back I do it
a lot of entrepreneurs do it it's a
great strategy it'll make you feel good
but it can't be your whole business
because there is no business there
you've got to look after yourself first
you've got to build yourself up and have
a company that can sustain you and give
you more resources and employees and
time and energy to go after more clients
and also help more people if you want to
do more good grow a bigger business and
help more people
and it starts with increasing your
prices you have to go after the clients
who respect what you do who value your
work and will pay you for it a quick way
to do it test your pricing so when
you're testing your pricing offer
different versions you never know what
people will pay for it start off with
your regular pricing and then try
increasing it ten percent thirty percent
fifty percent 100% you'll never know
what people will pay until you actually
start getting out there and increase in
the prices and testing it out you know a
lot of people are surprised by how much
people will pay in this this struck us
as a surprise when we were targeting our
corporate clients at the software
company we were able to charge five
times as much when we started it was
fifty percent more than it was double
then it was triple there was quadruple
we just kept increasing the price people
kept paying it it shocked us we weren't
ready for us we would never have thought
to go from the regular price up to five
times as much we just undervalued how
good our stuff was and that's what most
entrepreneurs do your stuff is really
good you better be if you want to be a
successful entrepreneur you got to be
awesome at what you do and if you are
then you need to charge accordingly but
if you're afraid to test it out then
start small doing regular pricing ten
percent thirty percent fifty percent and
go on from there it's a great way to be
able to test your pricing and start
getting paid what you're worth so those
are our four points get clients coming
at you create a board of advisors tell
your story increase your prices the
numbers a little bit off you'll see
they're 24 25 26 27 because these are
different worksheets that I have
available you can go check them out on
the website for anybody who does buy
from hearing the the webinar here let me
know and I'll give you another one for
free so buy one get one free special
promotion let's get to some of the
questions we've got one from Steven here
if you want to get in contact with the
celebrity for your book or other
resources check out contact any
celebrity site that's a great resource
Steven what I found was also helpful was
try to find a reason for them to want to
get in touch with you and get some
promotion so one thing that I do is
leverage whatever resource I have it the
star is my website so if you want a
celebrity to endorse you or talk about
you you have to get on there man
and to do that you need to give them
something of value right even when
people come to me and say Evan can you
come help us with this project there's
got to be something in it for me right
so what's in it for the celebrity so
what I would do right now I'd give them
an opportunity my website or might
interview them on a radio show when I
first started with my software company
one of the tools I created was a guide
to success from my field and I wrote an
article but most people wouldn't want to
read my article because who was I was
just some young punk kid startup who
nobody had heard of but then I contacted
all the biggest names in my industry and
I said would you mind contributing an
article to this guide that I'm creating
and it could be something you've already
written you know I don't expect you to
come up with something brand new just
for me because that requires a lot of
work you know make it dead simple stupid
easy for them and once I got my first
guy I used his name which people new to
get other guys and I collected 19 famous
people in my industry with their advice
to success and then included my article
with them and suddenly now I'm being
positioned with all these experts and to
get it you had to go to my website and
leave your name and information so it's
using as a lead generation tool once you
get your first guy you can go off and
get others use their name leverage their
credibility and you might start with
someone who's a little lower on the runs
with my website Evan chronicle com I
wanted to get Donald Trump involved in
the website but didn't go straight to
him I started with guys who are lower
down on the rung and started using their
names the pull up pull up pull up and
then when I went the Trump I said hey I
got all these guys involved in the
website how about you and you said yes
so you can apply the same strategy start
with guys who are lower down and work
your way up but you got to give them
something they have to have a reason to
want to stay involved next question is
from Rhys online we got Jason here he's
right saying most people don't want to
talk dark times what you mentioned
almost giving up on three hundred
dollars a month can you share more about
that please Jason is digging deep and
that's the kind of guy that he is he
wants the the mushy down deep raw stuff
that was tough man
I remember I graduated University and I
had opportunities to go work at big name
companies companies that only a year ago
would have jumped on and said yeah sign
me up this is my dream job and I was
working at my startup company and I
thought you know I'm going to give
myself a year I'm going to I'm going to
really try to do this and I said note
that those jobs where all my friends
went to take them investment banking
jobs you know they're making eighty
thousand dollars a year and here I was
struggling to make three hundred dollars
a month you know like that was
embarrassing for me and I wouldn't tell
them that you know I guess I had too
much pride to say yeah I'm really
struggling because we were all doing
really well at school and I was the one
who took the gamble and they were
supposed to be jealous of me you know
I'm the one going on in my own taking
the risk I'm supposed to be living the
entrepreneurial dream and I can't make
300 bucks a month well they're making
their 80,000 a year you know didn't seem
didn't seem right didn't seem fair I
remember having a pic people would
invite me out to events I had to pick
one thing that I could go to a month one
birthday party or one social event and
it would save up to go just to that one
thing because I couldn't afford to go
out with them you know seems like every
night that they want somebody wanted to
go out and I told him I was busy working
but really I just couldn't afford to do
it and you can only do that for so long
you know that was rough and I thought
many times about giving it up and going
and taking those jobs and hoping that
the opportunity was still there because
this entrepreneurial thing sucks but I
just seem to find a way every day to get
up and do it again and finally found the
way and one of the models that I use was
through looking at successful
entrepreneurs that's that's kind of what
helped save me when I realized I'm not
the first guy to try to sell software
before somebody else has already done
this why am i beating my head into the
wall every day trying to figure this out
when there is already a model out there
that works and I started looking at
companies like Bill Gates Microsoft and
Bill Gates and make
laughing into it looked at how they got
started you know how did they make that
first million again not how they make an
extra million dollars now who cares how
Bill Gates makes an extra million
dollars now but zero to one that's what
I wanted to learn and I picked up ideas
from them that I hadn't tried before and
I looked at ways that I could apply that
to my business and they started to work
and and finally we had some momentum in
our company and I'm so glad I didn't
quit you know it's so easy to quit it
could have happened any day I could have
quit because when you're not making any
money you know you can only go so long
before you quit and Jason I know you got
your own store too and for people who
are watching go look him up go check out
his YouTube channel because he tells his
story and it's a pretty awesome 12 but I
think every entrepreneur who's made it
has to go through that tunnel of this
fair where they almost give up and it
feels like the whole world is against
them and you don't know where that
lights going to come from at the end of
the tunnel but you just have to believe
that it's there and you just got to keep
driving forward every day until you get
a little bit closer to it that's what
you got to follow your passion because
if you're not excited about your
business you don't believe in your heart
that it's the right thing to do you're
going to quit it's going to be too hard
you're going to look at that you know
income statements you make it 300 bucks
a month you're gonna you're going to
bail out you got to do it even if you
weren't getting paid to do it because
you love it so much you do it you take
on part-time jobs to make ends meet so
you can still do what you're excited
about that's been an entrepreneur that's
how you know you're on the right path I
don't that was Ron emotional enough for
you there Jason but thanks for the
question let's see what else we got the
ttk rights in to say I'm looking to
launch an app soon any tips on how to
market it its exclusive for windows
phone thank you so thanks for the
question is on twitter the TT k first of
all I definitely look at expanding
beyond windows because most people are
not using windows phones so look at how
you can expand that if it's you
developing it or if you're bringing on
the team of people to help you that's
important I would start reaching out to
influencers right just like Dell eyes
explaining the webinar
here they reached out to me tried to get
me to use their new dell laptop that's
what you got to do you got to reach out
to influencers I don't know what your
app does the goal find bloggers go find
reporters go find influencers people on
Twitter or popular Facebook pages let
them know what you're doing try to get
them involved and I would tell your
story right why did you start this thing
make them feel the pressure make them
feel the excitement that you have for
the passion you've got behind it and ask
them to try it out get their feedback
make them feel like they're part of this
they're building something special
they're building something unique that's
going to be awesome and if those guys
endorse you and you get some feedback
from them then you're on the path they
have the audience they'll help you
spread the word to be my advice but
definitely built be on windows because
you know those guys are probably not
using Windows Phones anyways not to be
too harsh on Microsoft there i guess but
you got to be able to be across
platforms now you got to be able to have
it easy for everybody to use your app
and when you're telling people what you
do tell them the app right when you ask
me a question here i'm looking to launch
an app soon any tips on how to market it
tell me what it's about right like i
don't even know how to talk about your
business right now where I might have
people in mind that can say hey you need
to talk to this guy in this guy so
whenever you're talking about it make
sure you tell people what is that you do
thank you guys if you have any other
questions as always let me know and for
those of you who are watching the
recorded version on youtube if you like
it please give it a thumbs up below you
know I love seeing those come in and if
you have a comment about this video or a
question please leave it in the comment
section below I always with those makes
my day when they come in so thank you
and we'll see you guys soon